il ya quelques jours je vous montrais ce
nouveau smartphone de honor c'est le
magic quatre pros alors fois je vous
l'avais montré au mois de février
lorsqu'à été présenté à barcelone et
puis là on s'est fait une vidéo de
première prise en main pour le découvrir
et du coup ben je voulais aller un peu
plus loin au niveau du sujet parce que
au nord a vraiment fait le focus sur ce
smartphone en disant c'est un très bon
smartphone pour aller faire de la
création vidéo donc si vous êtes
créateur que ce soit sur tik tok sur
instagram sur youtube ou que sais-je
encore il ya beaucoup de plateformes qui
existe et plus celles qui émergent et
celle qui émergeront donnant autant vous
dire qu'on a quand même de quoi faire on
a un vrai potentiel est ce que le aux
normes j4 autant bon smartphone pour la
création vidéo j'entends est-ce qu'il a
des limites si oui quelles sont ses
limites c'est le programme d'aujourd'hui
ont été filmées avec un mois et mon pote
les on est parti filmer lors de la
soirée de lancement de ce smartphone en
grande pompe à paris on va donc se faire
un truc aujourd'hui en tout cas ces
dingos est en tout cas c'est rigolo on
va retourner dans cette soirée capsule
temporelle on va aller voir un peu ce
qui s'y passe il ya des coulisses on va
voir les équipes un peu différemment
savait très brune n'ayez pas peur les
équipes à tout va bien se passer je vais
vous en train de trembler comme ça parce
que c'est une vidéo qui a réalisé
aujourd'hui en partenariat avec honor
pour regarder si effectivement ce
smartphone est bon pour faire de la
vidéo vous allez en irak où les intrus
qui sont un peu en dessous mais c'est
normal ça smartphones et on y va tout de
suite
la question c'est est ce qu'on peut
faire un film de qualité un vrai bon
film avec le honor magic quadrant parce
que c'est la promesse que nous faut nord
alors il ya plein de modes différents là
tout de suite on est en train de filmer
en mode classique mais il ya également
le mode éclat soleil focus bravoure
éblouissant lure nostalgie l'udc ça
c'est ce qu'on va appeler des notes
c'est une colorimétrie qui va venir
s'appliquer directement sur votre
smartphone mais si on veut vraiment
faire du travail professionnel on va
utiliser des logs et le log c'est flatte
ses places et une image qui est pas
contrastées ya rien n'en est pour autant
elle contient toute l'image en termes de
couleurs luminosité ce qui fait qu'on
peut venir les dit il a travaillé pour
faire un contenu professionnel comme je
le ferais avec mon boitier lorsque je
fais des vidéos youtube donc aujourd'hui
ce qu'on fait on va faire un petit film
on apprend le smartphone en bas ce
manager m'a filmé plein de choses une
fois qu'on à se poser ce film je vais le
mettre dans mon ordinateur dans mon
logiciel d'édition dans ma timeline on
va venir les poser on va le monter en
passant rapidement on va venir le
colorisées on va appliquer une
colorimétrie pourvoir au final si oui ou
non on peut utiliser le mot nord magic
affrontent pour faire un travail
professionnel compas de l'édition repas
de qualité on remplit vidéo et sa
sauvegarde
[Musique]
au monde
regardez ce jour là vous êtes sur mon
ordinateur alors je vous ai ouvert je
suis sur ma came pouvait le faire sur
première si vous voulez ou sur un
logiciel d'édition quel qu'il soit c'est
pas très compliqué on va donc avoir
différents trucs vous allez retrouver
tous mes plans de gg tous mes plans dans
la timeline j'en ai a pas kg 56,1
minutes de rushes autant vous dire que
bon il ya quand même de quoi faire alors
je vais avoir des trucs un peu plus de
nuit je vais avoir des trucs deux jours
à l'extérieur je vais vous montrer la
première chose que je fais comme je suis
sur un format la voyait ses dix 3801 40
par 1920 c'est un espèce de 16 9ème un
petit peu cros p la première chose que
je fais alors c'est pas un tuto montage
loyal que je me remplit tout ça me
croque un peu l'image donc ça c'est la
première chose ensuite seconde chose
regardez on va regarder les différents
types de plans alors je voulais montrer
vous l'avez vu tout à l'heure j'étais au
début vous avez ces différents qualité
d'image ça c'est un mode naturel et on
voit qu'après il ya différents fils qui
vont venir s'appliquer c est ce qu on va
appeler du lot c'est un espèce de
filtres colorimétrie qui va venir se
poser en plus de votre forme anormale
d'image donc ces voiliers ya différentes
couleurs différentes ambiances et puis
après vous avez ce qu'on peut appeler ça
un format flat et ce format flat il est
intéressant c'est le format log parce
qu'en fait dans ce blog vous allez avoir
un peu toutes les couleurs qu'on va
pouvoir venir à travailler est dit et
quand on va venir faire ressortir pour
qu'il ya plusieurs outils pour venir le
faire vous pouvez le faire directement
ici au niveau des couleurs choisir votre
couleur là saturé par la ceinture et moi
j'utilise un plugin directement dans
final cut je veux dire donc bosser avec
ce plugin mais avant de mettre ce plugin
je passe par ce que j'appellerais un
agent payeur qui en fait une couche que
je lis reposer au dessus ça me permet en
fait de venir faire un état l'eau
colorimétrie de tous mes plans sans
embêter sans avoir à les faire un par un
et ensuite j'utilise un plugin qui
s'appelle cinéma great que je vous
recommande plus plus plus si vous êtes
sur final cut qui vraiment très très
très bon et voyez la joue monde juste
rapidement pour vous compreniez un petit
peu le principe et à comment ça marche
et ensuite je vais là j'ouvre mon
inspecteur et là j'arrive directement là
et là regardez je suis à voir donc tout
méforme avec toutes mes couleurs on voit
que ça marche bien j'ai aussi bien non
rougemont hier que mon bleu qui sont à
peu près pareil je vais venir déjà
commencé par saturer l'image parce que
je trouve très très très désaturer la
stature ensuite je travaille et je
montais mais hautes lumières voyez alors
je fais gaffe à pas venir je m'égare 80
90 % au-delà c'est un peu compliqué je
peux dire augmenter aussi l'expo parce
que je pense qu'on a plus ou sachs ici
voilà on a tout fait exploser je ne fais
ça comme ça je me fais une ope la
couleur des balances directement balance
des blancs clamé automatique je viens me
rajouter un peu de matière au niveau de
mes couleurs foncées menwar je fais
gaffe genre remonte un peu là et après
j'ai joué avec les mythes tonnes sur ce
que je veux je les sais à peu près par
là donc voilà un peu le principe de base
c'est vraiment le principe de base après
je peux venir contraste est un peu plus
mon image si je le souhaite en fonction
de ce que je veux faire ou pas et après
je peux venir ajouter une colorimétrie
je vous montre ça rapidement après je
vais faire un montage vous allez voir
j'aime bien utiliser celui-là le jive
règles 709 jeu n'est pas aussi fort
parce que là c'est un peu un peu punk je
le descends dans la lie en a pas du tout
et celui en maître imposant autour de
30% salem colorisées mon image et après
je fais les différents petits réglages
qui a derrière si je veux venir modifier
je met un peu plus froid j'aime bien
pensée froid et je viens un poil
réchauffer mon image que je trouve un
peu verte la réchauffe un peu mais pas
trop et je peux bien l'art sature un peu
mais pas trop non plus parce que je
trouve un peu dé saturer voilà un peu
mais pas trop parce qu'après ça va pas
être beau et après si j'ai besoin de
venir récupérer en expo vous voyez pour
mme éclaircir un peu je peux venir le
faire et une fois que j'ai ça regarde et
je fais un avant après donc ça c'est ce
que j'ai à travailler directement donc
il ya vraiment un process colorimétrique
un process d'étalonnage et de colo qui à
peu près je veux dire dans un process
plutôt professionnelle alors attention
parce que on reste malgré tout sur un
smartphone on n'est pas sur un boîtier
comme j'ai là tout de suite où je vais
aller plus loin au niveau de mon état
l'eau mais c'est l'idée en fait l'idée
c'est de vous dire je peux me refaire
une et à l'autre donc là je l'avenir
appliquer ça et alors l'idée aux plats
de le faire directement comme ça et ça
c'est vachement cool c'est que voyez je
les fais avec mon adjoint de lier sais
que si je veux et bien je peux venir le
désactiver très facilement envoyer avant
donc ça c'est mon fichier de base auquel
genre toutes les informations
colorimétrique et ensuite j'ai ça donc
là c'est un peu un poil tonique mais
c'est pas mal l'idée là ça va être de se
dire bon alors attendez pas ce qu'il va
falloir que des fois je le change un peu
parce que là je suis serein le jour si
j'arrive la nuit ça va être un peu
différent voir des trucs qui vont pas
être tout à fait les mêmes voyez là par
exemple la la donc on va regarder ça
donc là vous me laisser aller une heure
deux heures je vais venir vous mettre
tout ça en place je vais mettre une
musique derrière et après je vous
explique comment j'ai fait les
difficultés que j'ai rencontrées pour
voir si on n'y arrive pas parce que j'ai
déjà repéré deux trois trucs qui coince
un peu mais voyez là on est alors
effectivement c'est un peu clairet mais
il ya deux choses où on a un peu moins
de lumière et on arrive à sortir des
trucs qui sont assez cool et pour voir
qu'on est une fois de plus sur un
smartphone c'est intéressant on va
regarder si ce smartphone fallait que je
joue parfois les oliveraies laissez moi
un petit moment pour vous ça va
représenter le temps d'un claquement de
doigts pour moi ça va être un peu dans
la journée il faut me laisser avancer on
y va je vient d'éditer mon film au
travers de mon mac sur final cut pro
peut faire sur première le film que j'ai
tourné enfin qu'on a tourné avec un bon
pote les eaux avec le honor magic 4 po
et c'est vachement intéressant vous
allez où il ya plein de choses à venir
voir plein de choses cool mais avant de
vous expliquer je vous laisse regarder
le film il est très court et de fer a
peut-être une minute et quelques il
n'est pas très long regardez et après on
voit et on essaie de comprendre un peu
qu est-ce qui fonctionne qu est-ce qui
fonctionne pas on y va
[Musique]
la voix de
plus que ce qui se passe ici on est dans
une grande salle c'est la salle wagram à
paris dans laquelle va être lancée dans
quelques minutes officiellement le
fameux magic 4 rodéo non c'est super
intéressant parce que c'est la première
fois que honorable en france à 15 par
phone et une gamme et du coup on
pétition grand qu il ya plein de mots
c'est une superbe soirée il ya plein de
choses à faire et ça c'est super
chouette passe
m
sanaa
basta
comme je
savais que ce match
je
ça na na na na pas stocker
vous avez vu ce film je vous montre
regardez-la directement sur mon mac on
va essayer de comprendre vous voyez tout
et colorisé alors comme je vous
l'expliquais tout à l'heure je me suis
fait une petite colo directement ici
avec mon soft donc là j'ai gardé ces
plans là donc quand il ya beaucoup de
lumière vous allez voir ça marche plutôt
bien là le tchèque à leur premier petit
truc mais c'est parce que j'ai pousse un
peu les enclumes hier sur ce plan on a
un peu cramé ici mais très légèrement
mais c'est moi qui poussait délibérément
les hautes lumières pour récupérer au
niveau des cheveux ici donc ça c'est pas
grave ça me dérange pas ensuite j'ai
poussé la voyez donc ça fonctionne on a
une petite colle au sahb a choqué tout
va bien là ce plan là il manquait
légèrement de couleurs un peu plus noir
donc je suis venu rajoute un peu plus de
un peu plus de noirs je descende dubé
douar pour ajouter un peu plus de
contraste à l'image c'est pour ça vous
le voyez un peu hein pas celui là il est
filmé un peu un contre-jour donc je fais
une huile éclaircir légèrement dans les
taux intermédiaire et puis ensuite j'ai
laissé un peu la même chose pour qu'on
ait vraiment un truc très naturel
j'arrive là de doha lumière et dans mon
dos et bien éclairé dernier a lâché
sombre ou de vendre ses classiques là le
personnage arrive de face il ya la
lumière se fasse ça fonctionne donc vous
voyez tout ça ça fonctionne donc on peut
faire des choses sympas ici j'ai rien à
vous montrer particulier pareil ici
j'arrive un peu à contre jour donc j'ai
dû remonter un peu dans les tons
intermédiaire ils tous qui va être
vraiment intéressant c'est quand on
arrive déjà dans cette configuration là
et qu'on voit qu'on a des lumières qui
sont pas naturels en despote c'est là où
ça va être un peu plus dur pour le
smartphone vous allez voir que certaines
plutôt pas trop mal suis là je les
laissais comme ça mais je vois plus
vient de retoucher un peu sur les pots
mais bon j'ai fait le choix de garder en
l'état pour moi ça qu'on fait c'est
parce qu'on reste dans l'homogénéité en
fait du lieu et le smartphone ne sera
rendue qui est plutôt pas mal l'appareil
on se fait la bise tout va bien alors la
voyez ce truc qui marche vraiment bien
parce que quand on aille a dit vrai
éclairage sur fuck la star espèces
d'ateliers et quand vous avez cette
lumière assez forte assez naturel vous
verrez tout au long de la vidéo que ça
marche envoyé sur les peaux c'est très
sympa alors ce qui manquait sur cette
scène c'était un autre éclairage pour
unir éviter d'avoir des ombres derrière
mais ça fonctionne dans le cadre de la
soirée ça marche la vrillette la lumière
c'est pareil on est bien éclairée le
smartphoto sorte vachement bien donc là
dessus parce aussi on n'a pas le même
rendu que si j'avais un boîtier que ce
soit l'as et s3 que soit j'ai acheté ça
j'ai un style peu importe mais quand
même ça sera vachement bien j'irai pas
faire à broadcast avec quoi que mais
pour mettre sur le web ça là je peux
faire tout ce qui est vraiment cool
voyez les plans sont de bonne qualité
c'est pareil ça marche bien ce qui
m'intéresse c'est la petite lumière
derrière mais ça fonctionne là c'est
pareil on est avec l'éclairage donc tout
est bien optimisé là on allait
légèrement la lumière qui va venir baver
un peu ici c'est un peu la limite du
truc hein mais vous allez voir qu'on va
le retrouver mais sinon dans l'ensemble
je suis vraiment vraiment vraiment
satisfait bon là j'ai une lumière un peu
plus jeunes parce que forcément j'ai
l'éclairage de phase là qui est un peu
jeune donc c'est par là ce plan là je le
trouve un peu moins bien parce que pas
très bien éclairé j'ai un peu de bruit
sur la peau il est un peu plus de mal
c'est un peu moins évident pour lui pis
moi je bouge beaucoup donc là il aurait
fallu une autre lumière voyez on le voit
vraiment là au niveau de la peau si vous
regardez là c'est pas parfait c'est un
peu la limite du truc donc on fait un
face câble comme ça qu'on n'est pas bien
éclairé on sort des choses mais c'est le
truc qui va être un petit peu en dessous
sinon la regarder là ça fonctionne alors
la tchaux petits problèmes de sons un
peu cramé l'année parce que j'ai poussé
le plume hier pour pour ma scène ces
mêmes réglages jamais voyagé si je
voulais venir le modifier pour venir
leur toucher les décès les gens meurent
ici mais très honnêtement c'est du petit
point de détail ce qui compte c'est que
l'ensemble de la scène soit bien éclairé
ça ça ne dérange pas des masses vu qu'on
est sur du web alors après on est arrivé
dans cette partie active à oslo motion
en fait et c'est intéressant parce
qu'ils ont effectivement que le slow
motion fonctionne bien c'est très smooth
ça saccade pas ça marche bien après on
était sûr lumière rouge donc il avait
quand même vachement plus de mal avec le
spot dans la tranche donc là c'était un
peu plus dur pour lui mais je trouve ça
quand même une atmosphère qui se dégage
est que le résultat est somme toute
plutôt cali là c'est pareil ça
fonctionne ce plan là aussi alors là il
ya un zoom donc on a un peu plus de
bruit dans ce que je vous conseille de
venir vous rapprocher ne cherchez pas à
zoom avec votre smartphone
rapprochez-vous à chaque fois ça évitera
d'avoir des images qui seront un peu
moins bonne autant faute on pourra
détruire autant en vidéo c'est toujours
un peu moins bon là ça fonctionne et
c'était bien là également ça fonctionne
et la voyez c'est l'amour balle cette
lumière bleue qui est un peu plus de mal
on l'a au niveau des visages là un peu
de partout donc là cette lumière bleue
ils n'aiment pas ça ne l'aide pas ça
fonctionne dans la seine pour moi ce
n'est pas dérangeant mais c'est vrai que
c'est un peu la limite du truc en vous
et des lumières qui votre hyper forte là
at il un peu plus de mal là sur scène ça
marche pareil ici là on le voit au
niveau des applaudissements voyez
toujours la lumière
bleus là qui est plus difficile pour lui
alors j'ai fait un petit truc là on
entasse applaudissements en fait c'est
moi qui les ai rajouté en post prod
parce qu'ils y étaient mais comme
j'avais le sont derrière qui était pas
super j'ai rajouté les applaudissements
alors le sol on va en parler dans
quelques instants il vous montre un peu
les plans là c'est pareil on est bien
éclairée ça fonctionne bon éclairage ça
marche je me cherchais le truc un peu
proche un peu rapide comme ça pour
mettre en immersion comprend pas ce qui
se passe mais on reconnaît un peu les
personnes ça bouge le smartphone là
c'est pareil de la dynamique on danse et
on bouge là je mets bien cette scène
parce que je la trouvais un peu un peu
psychédélique là je trouvais que ça
fonctionne et ça apporte vraiment
quelque chose là le logo d'or aussi ça
marche voyez c'est pas parfait on a un
petit peu de bruit là sur l'image mais
c'est pas grave dans le cadre de ce
montage ça apporte de la dynamique donc
ça me dérange pas ça c'est pareil ça
fonctionne et à partir de là il a un peu
plus de mal parce que forcément moins de
lumière et les lumières qui vont être
moins bonne pour lui là on va voir un
peu plus de bruit la voyait là un peu
plus brut et je pense qu'avec moins de
lumière mais du coup il avait un peu
plus de mal ou alors ces quatre heures
qui avait du mal à les savoirs à star
c'est parce qu'ils étaient quand même
relativement tu as là c'est pareil on a
peu plus brut et mais on arrive à sortir
des choses donc c'est un peu moins bien
que ce qu'on a vu avant mais je trouve
que dans l'ensemble le taf essaie donc
pour moi ça remplit son rôle on est dans
l'ambiance de la soirée ça nous emmène
il ya un peu de bruine on comprend qu'il
ya moins lumière extérieure donc on
accepte ça est un smartphone s'en
sortira comme ça que l'on soit sur le au
nord qu'à trop où à aucun autre
smartphone très haut de gamme donc pour
moi il n'y a pas trop de souci là-dessus
ça marche là c'est pareil pour ça c'est
sa part qu'on avait assez rigolo ça ça
fonctionne l'ambiance de la salle est
alors là où est charlie où trouver le
mec qui n'a rien à voir avec la scène et
qui est venu squatter indice il est
couché est paraît il a banni si le mec
qui n'a rien à voir avec l'équipe mais
qui est venu ce côté-là photos et puis
après on termine avec un petit merci au
nord pour rita sur l'ouvrier je trouve
que dans l'enfant le boulot qu'il a fait
il le fait bien la retouche est agréable
on peut vraiment venir bosser et sur des
couleurs un peu différente un voyez là
je suis sur un truc comme ça ça va alors
j'ai pas fait un boulot à venir modifier
plan par plan on voudrait faire meilleur
étalonnage on pourrait étalonner plan
par plan mais si ce n'est pas le but de
vous montrer les talaud d'avoir une
colorimétrie parfaite maîtrise de tous
les côtés l'idée c'était plus d'avoir un
truc un peu brute en plus vivant de
comprendre comment est ce qu'on pouvait
venir édité ici en apportant directement
des lot 2 mon ordinateur sont des
lettres que j'utilise lorsque je fais
des montages donc c'est vraiment des
choses que j'utilise réguler herman et
qui fonctionne également là dessus alors
on vient et adapté on vient corriger ce
qui est le plus important pour moi c'est
venez vraiment choisir une scène avec un
bon éclairage fait votre cadre et puis
ensuite venez pas où mais passait pas
sur lui très grand-angle rapprochez vous
reculez rester sur notre capteur
principal qui fera le taf si vous êtes
un accessoire vous à des petits trucs
comme ça qui sont vachement cool sur
lequel pouvaient venir apposer votre
smartphone moi j'utilise tout le temps
lorsque je suis en vélo je suis dans la
rue je bouge je mets mon smartphone
dessus c'est pratique vraiment une
astuce super importante ne vous fiez pas
à votre caméra de self y retourner votre
smartphone mettez-vous comme ça et
faites lui confiance faites lui
confiance parce que vous aurez une moins
bonne qualité que la caméra de celle
fille alors après le deuxième point je
voulais vraiment voir avec vous qui est
important c'est de venir augmenter
l'audio parce que on reste sur un
smartphone et la qualité audio pour moi
n'est pas dingue voyez il ya une partie
par les tout le reste sur la musique ça
fonctionne mais la partie par les
imports elle est un peu en dessous alors
j'ai deux trucs peuvent aller je vais
avoir soit ce genre de micros on peut
venir utiliser et câblées directement en
usb c'est dans votre smartphone vous
prenez c'est pareil sans votre petit kit
vous le prenez vous le posez dessus et
là vous avez un petit kit prêt à partir
ou vous partez bloguer très facilement
voyez vous prenez comme ça vous vous
câble et tac et là vous avez un kit de
blogging alors tour notre sens pour
vraiment l'avoir sur la caméra arrière
ou alors il existe une autre solution
que je vous ai présenté l'autre jour et
que je vous recommande aussi à venir
utiliser avec ce smartphone pour un côté
un peu bloqué vous allez venir vous
exprimer ça va y être la solution dj
house et dj mike qui va être très bien
que j'utiliserai tout de suite pour
venir enregistrer vous brancher
directement dans votre smartphone vous
mettez le hf6 si vous avez des bonnes et
anti vent et ça viendra maximiser
l'expérience parce que on est sur un
smartphone ils font des trucs pas mal
mais je trouve que l'audio ça reste
quand même un peu en dessous mais bon
aujourd'hui vu ce qu'on va en
technologie ça me paraît pas déconner
donc moi je trouve ça vraiment
intéressant parce que si vous avez quand
même de la lumière et on va quand même
là quand il ya moins de lumière ils
arrivent à faire des choses c'est un peu
moins bien mais ils y arrivent donc à la
question est ce que le aux normes hadji
cap trop s'en sort pour venir filmer la
réponse est oui ce que je vous
recommande si vous êtes créateur contenu
si vous êtes youtuber si vous êtes
vidéaste il voulait venir feeling avec
ce smartphone ce que je vous recommande
c'est de venir filmer en flat vous
filmer en log et vous voulez mettre des
lottes après en post prod et là vous
aurez un truc qui sera bien vous allez
faire votre et anodajay vous allez venir
m volts dessus convenir colorisées
l'histoire et apporter une ambiance donc
voilà j'espère que ça va être très long
comme vidéo mais sur sa terrasse ans
parce que vraiment écoute tuto
comprendre comment on peut faire je
trouve que et je vous le dis une fois de
plus alors il y aura le test un complet
d'ici quelques jours mais je trouve que
au nord a bien bossé sur ce smartphone
parce que on arrive à faire des choses
intéressantes en vidéo on va reprendre
la partie photo dans quelques jours mais
je suis agréablement surpris c'est
intéressant également de voir voyez
comment est ce qu'on aura réussi à
monter sur le très haut de gamme en
europe en france alors qu'avant c'était
pas le cas dites moi vous ce que vous en
pensez de ce que vous avez vu ce que
vous trouvez que le boulot est
intéressant alors on se parle pas du
contenu qu'on veut dire mettre à la télé
intentions on se parle de contenus pour
le web on se parle de contenus destinés
à être regardées sur un smartphone mais
même destinée est regardée sur un ordi
pour moi il n'y a rien de choquant et je
trouve que voyez quand vous voulez un
petit appareil à la main qui fait
quelque chose de qualité là dessus vous
avez un truc est très cool mais filmé en
place c'est important parce que vous en
pensez en commentaire à chaud ça cool
j'ai hâte de vous lire et qu'on se
retrouve très vite pour continuer à
parler bien évidemment tech a parlé du
honor magic castro mais pas que et ça
c'est cool à bientôt 28 ans
il me dit